welcome back everyone thanks for
toughing it out to the last day the last
talk
very exciting uh over to you andrea
okay so uh
so just to summarize in the in the in
the previous hour what we saw is
basically the optimal error that we can
achieve
uh in an estimation problem by
algorithms that you know multiply by the
data matrix and apply some
component-wise operations so this is
basically the kind of question that they
are answering here is
what i can do if i can multiply by my
data matrix my a
1000 times i have my budget is 1000
matrix vector multiplication what is the
optimal error that i can achieve
or you know 17 and we can we can compute
the optimal network
uh
so you you might say okay uh that's not
that powerful you know multiply just
1000 matrix vector multiplication is not
a big deal
and uh okay this example shows instead
that
you know perhaps it can do something
interesting
and so the date the problem that i look
at is uh this character patrick problem
in which i want to
maximize this quadratic form
over the hypercube
and the w is a
geoe matrix but this is not really
important beginner matrix matrices work
as well
so this is the matrix and the scale of
the entries is 1 over square root of n
and okay in in following this it's
useful to keep in mind
that the typical value
is of order of this optimization problem
is of order n
okay
and this is very easy to see you know an
upper bound is
uh n
that is the norm of sigma the square
normal sigma times lambda max
of w the maximum eigenvalue and the
maximum eigenvalue is two right is two
so this is two n plus small of n
and you can achieve a constant factor
approximation
i don't remember the constant factor by
rounding
so again there is a completely explicit
lower bound
rounding
b
one of w so if you take w you compute
the leading eigenvector of w and then
you take the sign of that
this achieves a constant factor
approximation
so what i'm i'm really interested in is
not a constant factor approximation by
but
one minus epsilon approximation
and uh
okay so what the strategy will be
well the strategy would be to try to do
what we did in the estimation problem
and
uh
okay so so so in general
i can
okay let me write it like this
so the strategy would be to do a gfram
for a constant number of iterations and
and
well you know by the same reduction as
before the reduction that i gave you
before
doesn't doesn't use the the distribution
of the matrix i can always subtract this
on sagittarium to make my
asymptotics easy
yeah so and conditional on doing you
know provided i do some post processing
i'll be happy with this so at the end of
the day i compute some
let's call it z hat this will be some
press processing
of
that
zero
zt
i run for capital t iteration i do some
best post
and
you know
so this is the iterative part and what i
hope what what i hope is to get a plus
minus one solution
as you see the analysis of that i
described doesn't allow you to really
guarantee that every single coordinate
of that edit is plus or minus one by but
i
can guarantee things of the following
type for instance i can guarantee that
the distance between
z and solid cube minus one plus one to
the n
is smaller than uh square root of n
times epsilon
for any constant epsilon
the the state evolution alliance it
doesn't guarantee me that that is all
the coordinate for instance in this cube
but i can guarantee that
you know they are not too far from this
cube
and then what i can do if i do this is
that i can
compute sigma by rounding that
and and
and then show that so there is a
rounding step
that guarantees me that w sigma
is bigger or equal than that
w that
um
okay so okay if i can
guarantee that my z-head is
approximately in the unit cube
i can round it and i can get very small
loss in the function
okay
so i will not talk about this rounding
unless fourth two but so i'll for focus
on
trying basically to achieve one minus
epsilon
approx okay this epsilon is not the same
as the approximation error but one minus
epsilon approximation subject to the
vector being in the hypercube
okay
so now can what can
can we say about this algorithm
so any question about this
what can we say about this algorithm by
the same reduction
my previous
reduction
i can always assume
so
so first of all
if i look at this capital t iterates
by this i mean in the larger limit the
coordinates of these are distributed as
the zero
zt
t
objects
oh one thing okay how do i start this
i'll start this completely at random
so i'll start with the gaussian vector
with a very small thing so the picture
is the following
i want to optimize this quadratic
function
over the cube
and i'm starting
this is zero and i'm starting on some
sphere of radius square root of delta
square root of delta times n away from
zero
okay
and what i know is that okay but the
theory i know that i described before is
that any constant number of iterates
is distributed in the sense of the
empirical distribution
the teeth
and this law is well you know here you
have no signal
before there was a component in the
direction of you and a component that is
gaussian now this is purely gaussian so
this is
okay so if you give me a sequence of
functions
i can determine this asymptotic
covariance
and
okay so now
again you know thinking as before you
know by doing some post processing i can
restrict
two
uh
the covariance to be proportional to the
event
so i'll take the covaris to be that
okay
and at the end i will do some process
post processing
now just exactly what i wrote here
so what is the picture is that i start
at 0
and
each time i do a step of
radius of
length square root of delta and each
time i move in the direction orthogonal
to all the previous steps basically now
this is something
on the board i can draw it only for two
iterations
okay you can you can try to imagine it
and and the hope is that
you know
you know this kind of random work now
this is a random work if you look at the
work by itself so it's very strange
right i'm optimizing but it's just
because i'm not looking at the matrix
right the joint distribution of the
matrix and the work is non-instant
trivial of course
but the work is is by itself is just a
pure random work it's very simple
version of the book
okay so i should say that this idea of
going by orthogonal step here comes very
naturally but
in the context of these pin models
spherical models
uh you know
was suggested by a you know very nice
a per by uh eldiran swag
okay so this this this constraint uh
really simplifies uh my life
but uh
okay now i'll do a a a guess okay i
cannot do
all proof of optimality as i do it
before and now i'll do a guess
so i'll choose a specific sequence of
functions that guarantee that this is
this is true and one way
to get
a star
is to say the following
is to say i'll take my function f t
of z 0
the t
to be what to be
z t
times some function h t minus one
of z zero
z t minus one
and if you think now
you know as you see you can think of
this in terms of scalar recursion or
recursion of a vector where vector is
component wise so this is hadamard
product
entry wise product
all right so why does this
so let me call this
just for simplicity the variable ht
minus one
and so all of these objects have
corresponding random variables
that are denoted by capitals so as the z
of a capital z each have a capital h
that corresponds to so why this
guarantees that
you have orthogonal steps well it's very
easy
let's compute uh
let's compute
you know the the correlation between two
steps at time t plus one times s plus
the proof is by induction of course
because we have a recursion for the
covariance let's compute this
correlation
while this correlation by the state
evolution recursion and just apply the
state evolution recursion
is what is e
of
uh
let's move
ft
that that's recording
fs
z liquid
okay and now i plug this in
this is just the expectation
of z t
h t minus one
times z s minus one h s minus one
so let's see for simplicity what i want
to say
that t is bigger or equal than s
ah
the s yeah
if t is bigger or equal than s both this
okay let's let's do the case t bigger
than s for simplicity
if t is bigger than s you know this guy
depends on the t of course and all of
this guy
are measurable
on
z1 or zero that one
to that t minus one and all of these are
function of the first t minus random
variable so i can you know by induction
my induction assumption is that up to
time lowercase t
the the covariance is identity so by
induction this is
e of z t
times e of all the rest
and this is zero just by induction this
is
centered
i mean this is always centered
and what happens if if t is equal to s
if t is equal to s
now this is equal to e
of z t square
h t minus one square and again this is
measurable with respect to t minus one
so since gaussian
all right so by the induction assumption
this is delta
okay
so this works out if i if i impose the
constraint
so satisfies this satisfy star
if
i decide that i put the constraint that
e of h t
square
is equal to 1 for all t
this is just a constraint these are my
my function that i want to design right
so this is a constraint of this function
is just say that
the second moment of ht
of z1 or zero
the t
square
this is one
you can always enforce it by if you come
up with any sequence of functions by
normalizing them
this is this should be the right thing
right good question
we have an argument for that
yeah in a way an argument is the
following you see
this conception what i want to do is
take the steps that are very small right
so each of these z t is very small so
you can think of this as
your first order taylor expansion
and uh
well what i'm saying is that 0 4 that
has to be zero because otherwise if the
zeroth order is not zero i'll be in
trouble right now if you really take
this to the extreme to the
to limit t goes to zero there is
something a delta goes to zero
this condition
corresponds to the fact that the
integral of of the sum of the that you
see another way to say this condition is
that the sum of the z is a martingale
right
and uh
so that is a brownian motion
and
so i want this also to be a martingale
because i want this identity i mean the
integral of these two or this to be
martingale differences
and in stochastic processes there is
this
true fact that
you know if you have a martingale
measurable with respect to the brownian
motion you can you know
yeah very constrained way of how to do
it but okay to me the intuition for this
is really this kind of taylor expansion
but okay i don't i don't have uh more
more insight than that
yeah but if i i think if i take the
limit delta to zero
this is pretty much
the thing that you can do
okay so now so far i didn't talk about
this effect so
i i got away without talking at all
about this have had
uh let me
let me say up something about that
because that matters
in this
calculation so in this case
so in this case meaning for this choice
it turns out that the right choice of
effect that comes just from purely from
the general theory
is that this should be
the expectation
of
i think ht minus one
i think
you know html
times ft minus one
now in this case which is just whatever
it is that t minus one
times h t minus two
that's zero
the t minus two
so just the general theorem and i
brought the generation saying there
exists an effect in reality there is a
completely explicit formula for it that
in this case gives you this this simple
thing and then
i'll take it okay and
okay so so far i constructed an
iteration and this is
you know gives me a sequence of steps
now i have to tell you
how to compute uh the optimizers
well for optimizer i will i will do the
following
so
this is the
expectation of h t minus one
conditioned
nothing this is a completely
deterministic object
ht minus one is a random variable in
other words you know if you give me the
the sequence of function lowercase h
expectation of h t minus one
capital h t minus one it's just a short
way to write expectation of h t minus 1
of z 0
the t minus 1
where the expectation is with respect to
z i
i less than t
i id
normal zero
that
wouldn't be zero
simply because you take for instance
take ht minus one equal one
that is perfectly legitimate choice
given my my my constraints then this
expectation will not be zero
okay so now
you see now i have to come up with the
with an estimate for my for my optimizer
and you see the way i draw things the
natural thing to say is that i just
summed that
this would be a natural thing to say
first guess
this would be an actual first guess
of course it's not a good choice right
anybody can say why it's not a good
choice
each of this z is an independent
gaussian with variance delta
so this will be a gaussian
if i just sum it with variance delta
times t
i want it to be inside the cube with
that probability
there is no way it's going to be inside
i mean if it's inside the cube will be
very much inside you want to be very
close to a corner so this will not be in
any way close to it
yeah so if i take capital t of 1 over
delta i get the norm right
but still you know it will be uniformly
distributed on a sphere that doesn't
look too promising right i'm just
sampling it
okay so what i'm gonna do i take this
and then multiply by
and again somebody's gonna demand ask me
why
and i don't know why
this is the reality
i mean i tried a few things i actually
you know i
i knew the result right i know i know
the formula for the you know the parent
formula for the optimal of this problem
and you know
to some extent this is reverse
engineering you can make it more general
you can put here a generic function g at
the end of the day you can
figure out the g ph is the right thing
to do right so you can do all of these
steps a little bit more generally and
then try to figure out
nobody has done it so
okay so if you choose this thing then
what you know
okay now let's come to to uh boha's
observation what will be the norm of
this vector
the norm of this vector will be uh
in the
limit
and going to infinity this will be the
sum over s
one to t of the expectation
you see these are orthogonal steps okay
so let me write it
can you write
it would be the expectation of the sum
of z s times h s minus 1
square
square before the expectation but now
this is a martingale
so this is sum over s
1 to t
expectation of z s square
times h s minus 1 square
this is independent of this so this is
delta
times sum over
s1 to t
expectation of hs minus 1 square
and
and
and okay this is these are all ones so
this is t times delta
so even with this hs these are all one
by my constraint before so i want to
take to fix the north t
equal one over that so this will give me
the right norm
okay
so now that's it that gives you an
algorithm i have only to specify the
function h's
and
the thing that i need to do is to
compute
the value achieved by this algorithm
okay so let me compute the value of
shift by this algorithm
where do i do it perhaps i'll do it
there
so this thing is still doing orthogonal
steps they are just
not the orthogonal but they are not they
are all the same length
but they are not gaussian
each step is not gaussian
so they are orthogonal but they are not
independent steps unless unlike in the
okay so now what i want to compute is
that that
w that
okay and now what i do is that i just
write it
this is sum s t equal 1 to t
and then there will be
what
h
s minus 1 that
s minus 1
w
and then h
t minus 1
that t minus one
that's minus one s t
okay
so so far now i erase the algorithm so
what was the algorithm here though it
was that t plus one equals w
times z
t
times h t minus one
minus and then there is this coefficient
that is the expectation
of h t minus one
and then that
t minus two
h t minus two
this is this was ft
okay so i just now i want to compute
w you see what appears there is w like
times z t h t minus one okay this should
be superscript
and actually we're interested in this
divided by n in this bit divided by r
so this is just one over n
sum s
t
for the t
which s minus one z s
and then there is what
t plus one plus
e
of h t minus one
then there is h
t minus two
that's t minus one i think
i'm very i'm a bit sloppy but most of in
these indices likely don't matter too
much
okay so this is in the limit
is one over and oh the limit
goes to some of the s
necessary
sorry
i used only the i used just this
equation use that w times zt times ht
minus one
is the sum of this plus this
okay
so this converges to
uh so there are two terms one is
h s minus one
z is
the t plus one
and the other is e
of h t minus 1
e
of
h s minus 1
that is h t minus 2
t minus 1.
the nice thing about this you know state
evolution thing it allows you you know
freely to move between the
chinese and war that if it can work so
then
and what is this what you get
now the the zt so everybody is
well that's okay with this uh in the z
for my martingale
and the hd are you know measurable with
respect to the mass martingale
so
you know the only way that this term is
non-zero what it is
you see this this term by itself in
expectation is not zero if there is no z
t plus one the only way this is non-zero
is that this t plus one is equal to s
because otherwise one of the two will
kill the expectation
okay so the first term give me
sum over s less or equal than t minus
one
and then there will be expectation of z
s squared
times h s minus 1.
and something similar happens here the
only way that this is known zero is that
s is equal to t minus one so this gives
me sum over s
uh less or equal than t and bigger equal
than 2
and then there is e
of h
s
times e
of z s square
times of
hs minus 1 squared
okay very nice now this is independent
you know the gaussian is independent of
the previous gaussians this is
measurable with respect to
so this is measurable with respect to
that
one or that zero that s minus one
these guys are independent of this
so this is just the sum over s less
recorded
t minus one
h
expectation
of h
s minus one
and the same thing happens here times
delta
and the same thing happens here uh
so you get but now the expectation of h
square is
okay let's write it
delta
and now this our constraint is this is
one
and so these two term okay apart from
the first and the last index that would
be negrigible because i'll take delta to
zero so this is delta times the sum over
t12 capital t of expectation
there is a two
dimension of hd
some order that
okay so now we computed the value and
and uh
any question on this calculation
boss
so we computed the value achieved by our
algorithm
and
and
and now we are left with a with an
optimization problem over functions that
is very similar to i mean it's somehow
vaguely similar actually to the one that
i described before
so what is the optimization problem
we want to
maximize so
object i want to find
want functions
ht
from rt plus 1
to r
that are okay if it's continuous or
continuous
such that the following happens
such that for
uh
z t that are
a sequence of standard normal of normal
random variable width
with variance delta
we want to maximize
so what we want to maximize 2 delta
times the sum over t
one to t
t is one over delta
e
of h t
zero
z t
subject two
well that we have the constraint what
constraint we have we have the
constraint that we forced here
e
the second moment of each of this is
zero
is one
and uh
and okay something that i i now lost but
we want that at the end our estimate is
in the cube right
our our guy wanted to be in the cube
modulo
so what we want we want that the sum
over t
1 to t
of this random variable zt
times ht minus one of z zero
the t minus one
want it to be in
minus one plus one
remember this what it represent really
is a coordinate of my vector so each
coordinate must be in the
in the unit
intervals and this must happen almost
surely
with probability one
so no matter what are the sequence of
these discussions this has to be
okay so this is uh so i will not
so it's it's
friday 4 p.m so i'm not going to solve
it so this is an optimal control problem
it's a stochastic optimal control
problem you have a problem driven by
gaussian
noise
you have a process driven by gaussian
noise and you have controls that depend
on the past it's a discrete time
stochastic optimum control process
actually
each time you have
we have observed so many of these random
variables you want to decide the
coefficient to put in front of the next
random variable
is to end up in this so you're
constructing basically
now what does this look like between
zero and t it will be a marking deal so
this if i call this problem
this process i don't know
m
empty
it's the last er that
this is a martingale
so it will be something that
you want so at each time you know and
you want to bet
decide so this is
whether you win or or lose the next the
next bet and this is the amount of money
that you better the next bet
you want to decide the amount of money
on the next batch so that at the end you
end
up with a capital that is bounded in
minus one plus one
and you want to you know you have a
power constraint on your pets
and you have a
an objective functions on your pets okay
um now
you know the the optimal thing is
obtained okay so you can look at the
papers the paper in particular okay
there is one by myself and
better paper with mark selkie that is
here in the middle
where we we look at this
optimal control problem and what we do
is we take the limit delta going to zero
so becomes a continuous time problem and
then we look at the dual of you know you
can write an hamilton jacobi
equation in the dual of this hamilton
jacob equation and solve it
not solve it but get a variational
principle for its value
now in the case
for ascii model
what you obtain at the end is that the
value
of this
problem
up to a okay up to a mathematical
physics conjecture that i cannot
describe but now is equal to actually
the the optimal
so
this algorithm get that's the optimum
plus smaller one so i will not do go
into this calculation of the hamilton
jacob et cetera but
just to show you that this thing is not
something so
demystify a bit this optimal control
problem let me do a simple very simple
baby example
and even that i will not do entirely i
will just guess the solution
and the baby example is
maybe
example
is uh
drop
the constraint minus one plus one
so what that is does it mean dropping
the constraint minus one plus one
remember that the length of each step
now you know the real path is not the z
is the
is whatever it is the the z times h but
the z times h still have length delta
and they are orthogonal
square root of that
so you will find the point on the on the
sphere of radius square root of n
okay so the only if i drop this
constraint what i'm solving really
i'm solving
maximize sigma w sigma
subject to
[Music]
sigma this or equal then square root of
l
this is the problem that corresponds to
this baby example of course we don't
need all this machinery to solve this
baby example but
it should your algorithm should evolve
to the power method or something right
well interestingly it's not quite the
power method uh
interestingly so it's interesting is
that even this baby example we find
something slightly different
okay so let me let me let me solve it in
this case
so what i want to optimize is this one
so sum of a
one two t e
of h t
by kosher vars
this is less than than what
two delta
the square root of theta sum over
this is just kosher farts
and we saw that the constraint is that
these are ones
so this is
2 delta times t
and t is 1 over delta so this is 2.
wow so we we solve this we know that the
maximum egg value of this is two times n
so we solve the eigenvalue problem of
the factor epsilon not a big achievement
admittedly
but it's interesting so what is the
algorithm that achieves these
inequalities of course is
setting ht equal one every time
and so this corresponds to what in our
in our language
correspond to the following algorithm
this is w
then zt
minus
the t minus one
so so i'm not quite doing the power
method in the sense that
uh
you know i'm doing the power method i'm
correcting in such a way to be
orthogonal with time so each time you
are
so you're starting at some gaussian
vector and then we are multiplying by
this geoe matrix and then subtracting
the part in the previous subspace
so you are orthogonalizing one other way
of writing this is that
at each time if okay up to small error
this is roughly the same as this
actually i'm orthogonalized
so at each time i'm orthogonalizing with
respect to all the previous iterates so
a new power method
so each time i compute you know power
iteration and orthogonalize with respect
to the previous direction and then
orthogonalize again
and then i add up
all of this
it's not quite the same as power method
in a sense it's
it's a kind of uh
a bit surprising you know first time
that you see it works why it works so
you would say that you know you do 1000
iteration of multiplied by w perhaps you
are going in the right direction and now
all of a sudden you decide to move in
the orthogonal direction this seems a
pretty silly thing to do
right but if you think about it is not
so silly and the reason is not so silly
is the spectrum of
of this geometrics the spectrum of the
geome matrix is
you know spectrum
of w the empirical spectrum w is between
2 and minus 2.
so there is any eigenvalue there there
is a density and
you know between two and two minus
epsilon so what i'm trying to find is a
vector in this subspace between two
measures and there is
order n dimension here
that is c of epsilon times n dimension
that are good for me
here i'm doing capital t iteration order
one iterations
and i'm
you know it's okay if i drop capital you
know each time i orthogonalize it with
respect to whatever i achieved so far
it's okay right because in any case
so this is if you you can analyze in
other ways this algorithm what is really
computing is some polynomial of w
times zero and this polynomial
is an approximation of this of the
projection of this
subspace
[Music]
like as my eigenvalue gets closer to two
i mean if z
minus one had eigenvalue two then should
now subtract two times equals one
well you know i know by by by by my
analysis i know that zt
the s
will be
delta times uh
indicator of t equals right
so all of these
yeah
so if i run this algorithm
i know that it satisfies this this
properties
so i can take this
and hits on both sides by
the projection orthogonal to
t
and of course on this side i i get zt so
if i take this and
hit it on both sides
you get p orthogonal to t
p p to t p t is the projector on to z z
zero to z t and p orthogonalize the
orthogonal project
and this is zero if i hit it with that
and by this condition this is just the
same as the is very similar to zt plus
one so you're doing basically this
so at each time i multiply by matrix and
i'm moving
i'm projecting i'm only keeping
which if you think about it it makes
sense because you know
you should it's similar to what you're
doing conjugate gradient methods
you don't care any much about the
behavior of the metrics along the
directions that you explored so far
because
you already explored them
and yeah you can analyze this in other
ways for instance by
just spectral methods etc
and
so this is kind of reflective of this i
think that they are the way they were
the reason why this algorithm works
despite of
you know
you have order one number of iteration
is kind of analogous to what happens
here you cannot nearly optimizing this
function by moving in a lot of direction
there are lots of good direction that
optimize this function there is a whole
dimension and subspace that optimizes
this function
okay
yeah so um
i don't remember the name but this
specific thing people
call it what i mean
you you can you can look at this this
other way that i described i mean you
know the question is that linear ever be
everybody
pretty much everything that can be said
about linear algebra has been said
already
so you can you know any algorithm like
this will compute a polynomial of degree
t
of the matrix w
and multiply for by that zero
and now
now you can say okay what is the optimal
polynomial that i can compute here right
so you want a polynomial that does
ideally you would like the the
polynomial
this is not a projection it's really a
polynomial right and i really would like
this polynomial to be an optimal
approximation of the indicator function
over
p of x indicator function over
basically
x bigger or equal to minus epsilon
something like this
uh it turns out that people have done
this calculation and this gives
you know if you you know it's obvious
that it gives this it gives you know
some explicit uh formula in terms of
chebyshev polynomials and if you go look
at the recursion and chebyshev
polynomial correspond exactly to this
so we recover something that is you know
not the power i met but it's
actually more efficient this is more
efficient than the power method
but this uh
quite well
because power method is a specific
choice of the polynomial is the choice w
to the t right
uh can i ask a question can you hear me
from the zone
[Music]
it possible to describe exception yeah
i mean it's possible to describe them um
okay let's see
[Music]
no but there is no more conditional
expectation right this is the problem
it's not liking our first problem that
there was this clear bayesian estimation
structure that
can be exploited
uh
it turns out that okay one one okay i
can say a couple of things
uh one thing is uh okay you can define a
state that is another random variable
where first of all this is convenient to
think of time instead of going between
one and t to go between zero and that
and one we step
of length delta
okay
so i think of time you know as a grid in
the interval 0 1
and then the thing that i want to do
one way to think about it is that i keep
a state
x
that is
this delta times v
x t
t
uh plus some constant
times square root of delta times
zt
and then you say okay and then i'll say
h t
of that let's sorry call them t
this would be some function
g
of x t
and
right so now we have two functions uh
on the continuous variable this is a
function of r
dg
our function from r
times the interval 0 1
to r
i mean this is just a trick that i'm
okay you can do things a little bit more
general than this but
you're supposed to have variance delta
already yeah yeah sure thank you
yeah
okay so now
now if you constrain this to this then
it's very natural to take the limit
delta if it's very easy to take at least
theoretically to take the limit of
continuous time
delta very small
and this gives you this becomes a
stochastic differential equation
actually a can be one
and this becomes brown emotion
and hd is
hd
okay
and
and then
okay now you have to come up with these
two functions you have you know these
two functions turn out to solve
uh
a variation you know
so you write basically the hamilton
jacobi bellman equation for this and the
hamilton jacob equation
as is a dual it's a convex optimization
problem over these two functions and
there's a dual that is
that is uh
an optimization problem of a function in
the interval zero one
and
this b and g are given by the solution
of a certain pde
but okay it's kind of
it's all the dynamic programming and
yeah this is the short
i mean there is some intuition from
physics but i don't think it's
particularly useful
okay
[Applause]
are there any questions for andrea
i think there's a question
uh i tried to
find out if there's a question on
youtube do you know what it was
did it come up on the screen because i
am logged into the zoom but i actually
well no i'm not weather
i thought i saw
a question
there's something about
how tn
and
approximation at all right uh
can you hear me now all right oh no
no
yeah so this this okay so that what is
the the theorem that one gets in the end
the type of a plastic
okay so first thing this has been
generalized to other models by
you know in particular by mark and hamad
and uh okay so the type of theorem that
you get is that for any epsilon
uh there exists an algorithm
complexity
complexity
this is equal then c epsilon times uh
that's n squared so the matrix vector so
this basically is the number of
step
that achieves
probability
about
and uh so okay now of course all right
then dependence is very nice but the
action dependence is not known at all
and uh
okay so what will take to to do the
action dependence so this is basically
the number of step t okay
so basically i start with this
so if i let delta to zero so i go to
this continued limit i really achieved
the thing and i need to understand what
is the relation between these and this
this apparently seems not so difficult
because it's just a question of
discretization of stochastic
differential equation which is
something that has been very well
studied
but then there is
some now tricky technical issue that
arrives arises because of the
of uh
you know the formula basically how do
you prove that this is achieved
we have a formula for opt
we have formula that comes from this and
we compare the two right
and all of this theorem how also under
an overlap gap assumption
this is the technical assumption of
operational
program determination before
right so
so
you know
all the algorithm you can analyze
without the the these number of gap
assumption but to show that
the value achieved by the algorithm is
really opt you need this
so for really you know nailing down this
epsilon you need to understand the
properties of this variation problem
this is a variational problem over
functions
and so you know
this function kind of a strange behavior
we know how to analyze inspiration
yes
is it clear that this actually does
better than the spectral algorithm like
without any such assumptions or is that
also not
this is this is
you know that
clearly does better spectral
i think that you can very okay
so the spectral algorithm is basically
uh corresponds to taking here the
function g to be one
right i think that you can
quite easily come up with function here
g and b for which you can you know
compute the cost
so that you get better with respect
any solution
basically any solution you demonstrate
to this problem
will give you some number that the
algorithm gets at least this number
right so so it's already
possible numerically to show that this
is sure that the algorithm achieves
value
numerically
yeah yeah numerically you can you know
solve the variational problem
gets bound get bounds and
you know to show that the duality gap
closes we need this
laptop assumption to get your bounds
better than spectra i don't think it's
difficult because spectral is very it's
a very simple choice of image so it
should be very easy to
perform around this choice basically
spectral it's all the edges
one basically and then okay there is
some post-processing
let's thank andrea once more
[Applause]
maybe a round of applause for all the
speakers this week
you guys